caitlin: The title for today's self-guided is
caitlin: record a goose sighting.
caitlin: and the slug is
caitlin: UOCI. Dash RGS. Dash
caitlin: 10.
caitlin: Hello! My name is Caitlin. I am blind. And the assistive technology that I'm using today is talkback.
caitlin: which is android screen reader.
caitlin: To give you an overview of the task. Today I will be filling out a form about a a goose setting.
caitlin: And to give you an overview. How I use my screen, reader, I primarily navigate via swiping, swiping right to move down to the screen, left to move up through, up through the screen, double tapping to interact with any elements such as links or buttons.
caitlin: And if there's gonna be a lot of typing, I'll be using an external keyboard. But if it's just a little bit of typing. I'll use it on on screen keyboard. We shall see when that time comes.
caitlin: I will warn you that the double tap. Gesture sometimes does not register that has nothing to do with the website or anything like that. That's just a talkback Quirk that I've run into. And I will also be holding my phone up at an odd angle because I'm unable to in share my internal audio with Zoom.
caitlin: okay, let's get started. I'm gonna swip to the right
caitlin: link, skip to main content. Link is. It's not a real government service, and it's training purpose. Only
caitlin: good is not real service training purposes. Only you'll have to create your own way of drinking. Sorry
caitlin: you have to create your own way of registering geese.
caitlin: link one free for items, home link, environment and countryside
caitlin: environment and countryside link. I like Microsoft
caitlin: Link, free wildlife and biodiversity link.
caitlin: Anyone recorded goose signing.
caitlin: But start now, button. Okay, so far, this is perfectly accessible. Let's double tap
caitlin: 0% progress or 51%
caitlin: love you.
caitlin: Page is loaded. Let's swipe right
caitlin: doing content. I'm curious if this top part is actually change. So let's look over the web page.
caitlin: Okay, cool. We didn't have any of the previous links. That's perfectly fine. Do you like east heading level one so like you asked if you like East
caitlin: Select? Yes, if you like. Geese. Gotcha
caitlin: option one, too. Not checked. Yes.
caitlin: yes, no. So let's check make sure we can check both
caitlin: in group option 2 with 2 no.
caitlin: in group. I'll tell you what to? Yes, not check.
caitlin: Okay, yes, gotcha.
caitlin: No. I'm kind of neutral towards skis. I don't like them and dislike them. So I'll just put yes.
caitlin: in group option 202.
caitlin: No, continue. Continue. Continue button. The special instructors. Instructions did say I could explore the links. I'm gonna make sure there's nothing else on this page. Nope, okay, because we veered into the annotation for the zoom controls. That is the end of the web page perfect.
caitlin: That's switch our close tabs. Give it a second.
caitlin: Continue
caitlin: that has nothing to do with the website. That was talkback closing focus for no apparent reason. Usually, when swapping over from the zoom controls, it takes me back to the
caitlin: very bottom element or bottom location on the page, and it did not. So that's nothing to do with this page. So let's double tap on. Continue
caitlin: oop records signing with you.
caitlin: Alright, we're recording goose siting. It says record. This is web view to let us know we're on a web page. So let's swipe to the right content.
caitlin: Skip them in content. Let's try that double down. What type of 2 Cdc.
caitlin: anyone? Okay, tell us what type of business it was. What type of goose did you see? Tell us what type of goose it was. What type of goose did you see anyone, those goose
caitlin: ghost goose? Tell us what type of it was
caitlin: I don't understand. Tell us what type of business it was.
caitlin: Eddie Box. Tell us what type of goose it was. Blacks for wink. Tell us what goes gooons? Oh, this is interesting. Okay, cdc.
caitlin: anyone. So I see the word ghost goose. I don't know what that means. Tell us what type of it was
caitlin: might be an example, goose continue.
caitlin: Maybe that's just an example. Alternative filling options available. Backspace
caitlin: windows. Sounds on keyboard.
caitlin: Bye? Bye. okay, yeah, there's there's nothing to type. There's nothing to type in there. So must be an example. That's perfectly fine. The ghost goose kind of threw me, though that was kind of funny. I think I'm gonna type it. I saw a ghost goose
caitlin: wait. But if I type that, then then I can't change my answer to that. Okay, let's just type I don't know any types of goosees, so I apologize. But I'm just gonna make something up. I don't know what it said. Black Spurgoo. So let's just say, black pink
caitlin: goose, how do you smoke? Goose? Okay. Doesn't seem a spell.
caitlin: I'm awful at spelling. I apologize if I spelled that wrong, and
caitlin: I'll kind of fill up and talk back. Did not
caitlin: catch that alright? So let's touch some random screen. Tell us what type? Editing.
caitlin: The reason why I had to touch touch somewhere in the middle of the screen is because once when I turned off my Bluetooth keyboard the on-screen keyboard pop back up and talkback focus would now be in the keyboard. Tell us what type focus it was
caitlin: editing. I think it was alright perfect. That's what it wrote. Can you? Let's double-tap on continue
caitlin: 0% progress bar, keep working 20%.
caitlin: When did you see the dews records signing?
caitlin: When did you see the goose get the main content. When did you see the goose?
caitlin: Anyone, for example, April 1617,
caitlin: and a Box day box on a box day?
caitlin: I'll try different options available about the keyboard. Use standard keyboard. No, I will use the external keyboard, because numbers are fairly easy.
caitlin: to type. I run my finger across the screen when I find the letter number that I want, I lift and it types it.
caitlin: 4 windows sounds 24, 7. Here, for example.
caitlin: Wednesday, edit. On Box day.
caitlin:  36. Window, Samsung free.
caitlin: 0
caitlin: 8 0 0 and a fuel.
caitlin: The reason why I press 0 and lifted sometimes if you lift
caitlin: wrong, if you left a little too weird it doesn't enter the number. I've noticed that, especially with the with the 0. I'm not sure why that is, that's talkback work.
caitlin: When did you see the news?
caitlin: Anyone? Okay, it touched in the middle top of the screen. Don't wanna swipe, for example, 30.
caitlin: Okay. Perfect. Does editing 30.
caitlin: keep more, John.
caitlin: Alternative filling options available about the keyboard.
caitlin: we will say 12
caitlin: windows, one.
caitlin: 2, 200 continue year.
caitlin: Franklin, can you see the news
caitlin: editing 12
caitlin: windows, 0,
caitlin: 0, 2, 3 free and a field
caitlin: 2023.
caitlin: When did you see the news? For 31, 12 year, editing
caitlin: 2023 continue perfect. Continue button double tap.
caitlin: 0% caucus far keep working. 20%. Check your answers according to signing.
caitlin: Okay, the keyboard was hidden, and then the page load. loaded content. Check your answers for sending your application.
caitlin: Anyone check your answers before sitting your application, heading low. One
caitlin: goosey tales you like East. You like East. Yes, definition change biscuits.
caitlin: Oh, this is change biscuits, link. I don't know what that means.
caitlin: Type of goose that you saw black wing, goose, black wing, goose, pinky change what controls, links, speech rate characters, words change. Take
caitlin: charter. C, okay. Tech.
caitlin: CAKE. Oh, cake. I hope I hope these are intended to be random
caitlin: random words in these links, because that makes no sense. I would expect something like change or answer
caitlin: link that actually makes sense. Alright. Let's keep logging. See if there's anything else on the page. Thank you. Now send your application. Hail to. I submit this notification. You're confronting that to the best of your knowledge details. You are providing our prep.
caitlin: Okay by submitting this notification, etc., etc. I can't review it. All that like will be here forever if I try. But it's understood and appreciated. Last.
caitlin: what happens to my data
caitlin: collapsed. What happened with my data? Okay, and special instructions did say, explore everything the page. So let's see, let's make sure we can expand this, expand it.
caitlin: Nothing. This doesn't actually do or block anything. You'll have to store your own goose records. Unfortunately.
caitlin: Okay, perfect. Expand it. What happens with my data? Let's go for my email.
caitlin: Alright, out last
caitlin: perfect. Continue.
caitlin: Okay, very cool. Yeah, you're lucky. Yes, can just get. Thank you. So thank you.
caitlin: Alright, thank you.
caitlin: Like, let's change this to 0%. Okay, 20%.
caitlin: Oh, I can do signing.
caitlin: Yep! What type of goose goes? Tell us what type of news it was
caitlin: that makes me laugh. I don't know if that bit of text is supposed to be there. But I think it's funny
caitlin: lines what characters teach.
caitlin: Oh, St, okay. I thought it was missed. Right? Tell us what type any box tell us what type of this it was black for winks.
caitlin: alternative filling options available about the keyboard. Think what you ask, Rachel use, and our keyboard
caitlin: windows sounds cheap. Hmm.
caitlin: thanks, sir. Go, sir. Okay, no.
caitlin: That face let me just face. That's nice. Let me talk.
caitlin: Thanks for awesome.
caitlin: That is why I don't like typing on the on screen keyboard. If you lift wrong, it will. Even as you're lifting your finger, it'll for some reason move to the next
caitlin: letter.
caitlin: That's nice. Okay.
caitlin: Oh, oh.
caitlin: thank you. QW.
caitlin: Tell us what type of cause it was, what type of goes. Did you see? Okay, anyone Cisco scoops I can actually check and make sure I spoke goose right? So how I'm navigating by word and by character is, I'm swiping up or down with 3 fingers, controls
caitlin: thanks.
caitlin: lines, words, until I hear the value that I want, and then I swipe down
caitlin: and then swipe. I think, up characters. Yeah, there we go now. To characters, so I can see how it's something that's felt. I step down.
caitlin: Oh, SE, wow! I spelt it right? Yay.
caitlin: okay, so let's find the continue button.
caitlin: Let's first make sure that ghost goose has been hindered. 20.
caitlin: When did you see the goose recorded signing.
caitlin: When did you see the goose? When did you see the goose.
caitlin: for example, day and a box month at a box day?
caitlin: It took away.
caitlin: It took away the day. The date. Basically. That's unfortunate.
Gotcha
caitlin: 0.
caitlin: Continue at a box near
caitlin: right? When did you see the news here? And a box here.
caitlin: Talk. Friday's being weird. Thank you. Editing.
caitlin: and it box on.
caitlin: I'll kind of 4
caitlin: windows. Have one
caitlin: continue, and up here
caitlin: oh, something else forgot to forgot to mention when I'm using the long screen keyboard. The reason why I know things have been entered is because it provides haptic feedback to let me know something has been entered here.
caitlin: 0 2,
caitlin: 2, 2 in a field. So we'll do a different date this time
caitlin: free. When did you see the news? For example, if day 30
caitlin: editing continue
caitlin: editing 2022. Continue
caitlin: moving between these things. I'm just pressing pressing. Sorry. I'm just swiping to the right or to the left, so to move forward right to move backwards. Left.
caitlin: Get the main content. Check around details like, okay, goose details. And all 3, you like east
caitlin: definition, definition.
caitlin: Alright. Now, I'm to submit my application last. continue
caitlin: continue 0%, 70%
caitlin: just recorded records of signing
caitlin: with you. Skip the main content just recorded.
caitlin: Thanks recorded
caitlin: your reference, number your reference, number information.
caitlin: Thank you.
caitlin: Take a look at the answers.
caitlin: or if you want to have another check, go back. If you want to have another check, go back to the start in to start. that should be it. Let me look at the instructions.
caitlin: Okay, submit your application. The task ends here. Okay, I have submitted it.
caitlin: The only bit of feedback I would suggest is, if the continue button on the previous page to submit. This application is actually labeled, Submit, then it should be labeled, Submit because continue made it sound like there was more application to do.
caitlin: But that's honestly the only bit of feedback that I have for you. Everything else was perfectly accessible, and it made sense.
caitlin:  yeah. So you know, headings, links, edit fields.
buttons. The little expandable.
caitlin: A question that made that made sense.  yeah, everything makes sense. So this appears to be perfectly accessible.
caitlin: At least everything that I interacted with was the skip to link work perfectly. So, yeah.
caitlin: thank you very much for allowing me to follow my thoughts on feedback. Thank you for your continued commitment to accessibility and thanks for listening.